everyone is the night after the annual
Met Gala aka one of the most extra red
carpets of the year we've got everything
you miss and everything you need to know
from fashions biggest night and listen
love it or hate it it's hard to look
away from all the spectacle and let me
tell you something the stars got into
the Holy Spirit dressing at this year's
theme heavenly bodies fashion and the
Catholic imagination case in point this
Katy Perry who took flight with these
massive angel wings above that gold for
Saachi stunner she flew solo without
boyfriend Orlando Bloom but Katy
confessed in the limo she was hiding a
precious memento from their recent trip
to the Vatican a rosary blessed by Pope
Francis himself you know Kim Kardashian
also went stag but she was holding court
and her gold Versace as well so we're
with Kanye well Kim tweeted he is
finishing up five albums folks meanwhile
Kim's sister Kylie and Kylie's baby
daddy Travis Scott got to have some
mommy daddy time the couple also became
instagrams most liked photo from last
night's event now inside the gala
Kylie reunited with Selena Gomez who
attended last year with then boyfriend
the weekend and this year she just kept
it a girls night speaking of how's this
for a girls trip Tiffany Haddish made
her Met Gala debut and apparently she is
also a saint bringing together both
cardi B and Nicki Minaj now it's hard to
tell just from this group shop but the
rapper's seem to squash any signs of a
feud at least once they got inside but
could we talk about how they looked like
they're dressed like an angel in the
devil we actually have more on Nicki's
devilish look in just a few but nothing
was more angelic than the musical
stylings of Miss Madonna Madonna pretty
much wrote the book on this year's Met
Gala theme and inside she surprised the
crowd with an intimate performance of
the only choice for the night of course
Like a Prayer
[Music]
ah Mads the patron saint of nostalgia
that looks so epic clearly the
performance look like one for the ages
guys but I'm not sure anyone had as much
fun as Frances McDormand she was clearly
living her best life in Valentino and
her look was capped off with this
massive Philip Treacy headpiece and she
told us it only took her five minutes to
get dress but you know what you didn't
see was Francis rubbin elbows or taking
a nap with John boyega Lina wave and the
Black Panther cast blink and you might
miss them
[Applause]
I have no clue what she's doing there
but I feel like on a night like this
with so many stars and the fashion
industry elite you just got to go full
bonkers speaking of the night was full
of memorable and some outrageous looks
and to help break down some of our
favorites of the night please welcome
eet's he's senior style editor Marisa
Runyon oh I think is that carpet it's my
favorite red carpet of the entire year
it's the one event I would go to if I
could pick any red carpet in the world
that's the one I'd want to buy because
you're allowed to go over the top and
this year's theme was perfect for that I
was and I know it's hard to pick we
actually heard a lot of feedback from
you guys on your favorite outfits last
night but course I'm staying up for you
well you have to talk about Rihanna I
requested there's so many things to say
about Rihanna so in addition to being a
co-chair of the event she is wearing
custom makes on Margiela by John
Galliano and she is just giving us
everything we want to see at the Met
Gala she's wearing an over-the-top
beaded cage on top of this little mini
dress this insane pontiff hat she's
literally the Pope of the Met Gala all I
could say to that is Holy Mary Mother of
God like pray for us sinners like she
shut down the carpet we knew she was
dressing to the theme and this one was
this one with was her piece tis a resist
also you don't my winner of the night oh
no I just I stopped breathing for a
second when I saw her on the and I heard
that it took 250 hours to sew and 500
hours just saying I'm gonna embroider
that stuff I mean it's beautiful every
single piece of that look had it so much
attention put anywhere speaking of
attention Blake Lively also shut down
that carpet in this light real Lively
that's what I would because she looks
sexy but beautiful and elegant and and
theatrical she is wearing Atelier
Versace a so many millions of dollars of
Lorraine Schwartz jewelry and that train
was so big and her gown was so big that
she actually took a party bus get to the
event because she had to get in the car
and not crush her gown a party bus and
an ensemble to help her walk up those
metal steps I love that well I also love
that she actually dyed her hair to match
the color of that
yes that's what her stylist said they
were
into account the patron of gold in the
gown and her golden blonde that is
someone else who can do no wrong she's
given JLo a run for her money who's one
of my favorites of last night - right
JLo looks done stunning come on now I
mean that body not fair so - and she's
approaching 50 - but girl looks good
like so so good she's wearing him on
wearing pom on and again like on theme
but on JLo totally right still her own
brand she's still giving us full JLo I'm
loving that side part hair - and of
course the best accessory of the night
was a rod and the two of them actually
celebrated a red-carpet anniversary and
they talked to et's Kathy Knight all
about it awesome here
allowed to happen I mean this is
gorgeous I couldn't believe when I first
saw her today so now two teens got
engaged earlier on these steps could
there be a wrong wedding in the future
for you guys why with so no wedding
bells just yet for JLo but as she
mentioned rapper 2 Chainz did put a ring
on girlfriend Keisha Ward if he proposed
at the Beatty Awards five years ago but
they still haven't tied the knot so well
better place in the met right I mean
that's where I'd want it to happen I
love it let's hope no more Clooney yes
I'm all Clooney so she's again goals
just fashion goals in general everyday
and she is breaking rules and that's
what I love about for look last night
she is wearing richard Quinn he's a
British designer she's wearing trousers
underneath this humungous beautiful
floral over skirt and again Lorraine
Schwartz jewelry and it's dripping in
diamonds she's no elegance she's so
elegant what she was doing by showing up
early to like all the kid the photons
were going insane fur and I do love that
she's wearing trousers
the designer actually told us that she
was wearing pants to kind of be a symbol
of female empowerment yes which I love I
love when people actually take the theme
into you know a really personal place
and and tie it all together I love it so
when you guys love that you wanted it to
talk about was Priyanka Chopra and I
could see why I mean look at this she's
gorgeous she's wearing Ralph Lauren and
again her makeup look last night was so
beautiful she had this glittery eye this
headpiece was amazing headpiece is worth
theme of the night everybody really
brought it with a headpiece and she just
looks so elegant and and glittering
totally so what do you mentioned head
pieces that I saw Chrissy Teigen she
tweeted she was like all I want to do is
wear head pieces the Met Gala on the
one-year I don't go everyone and then
she instagrammed her own hair which was
like a Fed head bun from three different
angles she's about to have a baby guys
so of course she had to skip out of the
carpet but that was hilarious
there were a lot of head pieces yeah
Nicki Minaj I mean
we talked I told you we're gonna talk
about her devilish look and that's
exactly what it looks like so I love
when everyone took the theme into a
really angelic place that she sort of
went the opposite she said I'm gonna
dress like the devil I'm gonna wear
bright red she's wearing Oscar de la
Renta it's a liquid sequin
so it just skims over her body and then
she has this multi-layered
dipped coat to match tulle and we also
talked to her on the red carpet where
she gave us a little clue about the
inspiration behind the look and you know
what some are seen it might be a little
bit of shade but you guys be the judge
yes Miz Minaj darling you looking
fabulous first of all tell me about this
look the pressure of the I don't know
who that was aimed at but leave it to
Nicki to Talk That Talk
the designers actually behind her that's
Fernando behind letting her train the
actual designer of Oscar de la Renta
it's amazing anything for the photos
right at that moment you know she also
revealed to us that her new album is
coming you guys it's called Queen and
that drops June 15th but before we go
could talk about the fellas last night
cuz I feel like they really showed up
cuz they really brought it too right and
they have to stay on theme why not so
there was a lot of brocade there were
capes chadwick boseman in Dolce & Gabana
that's right really bringing it he's
giving us this amazing cape the gold
shoes the whole thing was just awesome I
thought he really went for it my best
friends just asked me to officiate their
wedding and I literally sent them this
photo chalica but I know what I'm
wearing when I marry you guys like that
is so good what absolutely right just a
little bit and in white of course what I
love about it is that a lot of the guys
show up in Texas yeah but they really
lean into the theme this year so that
was so fun yeah okay I love all white Oh
like I missed you guys it's so hard to
pick the best dress there's still plenty
plenty more but who you who are you guys
loving let us know in the comments
section and of course we have more Met
Gala coverage including the couple's
confessions and of course more heavenly
fashions up on our site ET online.com
and tonight on ET so until then like and
share this video and we'll see you guys
Rob bye
you